- ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่ Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation
ผมชื่อ John Watrous และ
ผมเป็น Technical Director ของ IBM Quantum Education
นี่เป็นบทเรียนที่สี่ของซีรีส์ และเป็นบทเรียนสุดท้าย
ในหน่วยแรกของซีรีส์เกี่ยวกับพื้นฐาน
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม
จนถึงตอนนี้ เราได้พูดถึง
วิธีที่ข้อมูลควอนตัมทำงานสำหรับระบบเดี่ยวและหลายระบบ เราได้ดูโมเดล quantum circuit
และเราได้สังเกตข้อจำกัด
พื้นฐานบางอย่างของข้อมูลควอนตัม
ระหว่างทาง เราได้
พบแนวคิดทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่สำคัญ
รวมถึง tensor product และ inner product และเราจะยังคง
ใช้แนวคิดเหล่านั้นต่อไป และจะแนะนำแนวคิดใหม่
ๆ เพิ่มเติมตามที่จำเป็น
ในบทเรียนนี้ เราจะ
โฟกัสที่ตัวอย่างพื้นฐานสำคัญสามอย่าง คือ quantum teleportation, superdense coding และเกม CHSH
ซึ่งเรียกอีกอย่างว่า CHSH inequality และไม่ได้ถูกอธิบายเป็นเกมเสมอไป
นี่ไม่ใช่แค่ตัวอย่าง
สุ่มๆ ที่มีไว้แสดงวิธีทำงานของข้อมูลควอนตัม แต่เป็นส่วนสำคัญ
ของรากฐาน
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม และ
มันปรากฏขึ้นในสถานการณ์ที่แตกต่างและบางครั้งไม่คาดคิดภายในข้อมูลควอนตัม
และการคำนวณ
Entanglement มีบทบาทสำคัญในตัวอย่างทั้งสามนี้
และที่จริงแล้ว entanglement เป็นสิ่งที่ทำให้มันทำงานได้
และทำให้มันน่าสนใจ ดังนั้น บทเรียนนี้จะเป็นโอกาสแรก
ที่เราจะได้เห็น entanglement ในการทำงานจริง
และเริ่มสำรวจว่าอะไรทำให้ entanglement น่าสนใจ
ภาพรวมของ
บทเรียนนั้นง่ายมาก เราจะไปทีละอย่าง
ผ่านตัวอย่างสามอย่างที่ผมเพิ่งพูดถึง
quantum teleportation
superdense coding และเกม CHSH
เราจะพูดถึงว่าสิ่งเหล่านี้คืออะไร อะไรทำให้มันน่าสนใจ และเราจะวิเคราะห์อธิบายว่ามันทำงานอย่างไร
ในระดับคณิตศาสตร์
ก่อนที่เราจะไปถึงตัวอย่าง
แรกจากสามอย่าง ซึ่งก็คือ quantum teleportation เป็นเรื่องเหมาะสมที่จะ
แนะนำตัวละคร
Alice และ Bob ก่อน ในกรณีที่
คุณไม่คุ้นเคยกับพวกเขา
Alice และ Bob เป็นชื่อที่ใช้
เรียกตัวแทนหรือเอนทิตีสมมติในระบบ โปรโตคอล เกม
และการโต้ตอบประเภทอื่นๆ ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับการแลกเปลี่ยนข้อมูล
พวกเขาเกิดขึ้นครั้งแรกใน
บริบทของวิทยาการเข้ารหัสลับในทศวรรษ 1970 แต่ธรรมเนียม
ในการใช้ชื่อเหล่านี้แบบนี้ได้กลายเป็นเรื่องปกติมาก
ในบริบทที่กว้างขึ้นมากตั้งแต่นั้นมา แนวคิดก็คือ
ชื่อเหล่านี้เป็นชื่อที่พบเห็นได้ทั่วไป อย่างน้อยในบางส่วนของโลก และขึ้นต้นด้วยตัวอักษร A และ B
และยังสะดวกที่จะ
อ้างถึง Alice และ Bob ด้วยสรรพนาม her และ him เพื่อความกระชับ
โดยปกติเราจะจินตนาการว่า Alice และ Bob อยู่คนละที่ และมีเป้าหมาย
กับพฤติกรรมที่แตกต่างกัน
ขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเรากำลังพูดถึงอะไร
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรา
กำลังพูดถึงการสื่อสาร คือการส่งข้อมูล เราอาจกำหนด
ให้ Alice เป็นผู้ส่ง
และ Bob เป็นผู้รับ
ข้อมูลที่ถูกส่ง
บางครั้ง Alice และ Bob
ร่วมมือกัน ซึ่งเป็นเรื่องปกติ แต่บางครั้งพวกเขา
แข่งขันกัน หรืออาจมีเป้าหมายต่างกันที่อาจ
สอดคล้องหรือไม่สอดคล้องกัน
แต่ทั้งหมดนี้
ต้องระบุให้ชัดเจนในสถานการณ์ที่กำลังพิจารณา
แน่นอนว่าพวกเขาเป็นตัวแทนของสิ่งที่เป็นนามธรรม ไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็นมนุษย์จริงๆ
เรายังสามารถเพิ่ม
ตัวละครอื่นๆ เช่น Charlie และ
Diane หรือชื่อต่างๆ ที่แทนบุคลิกต่างกัน เช่น Eve
สำหรับผู้ดักฟัง หรือ Mallory สำหรับคนที่มีเจตนาร้าย
ขึ้นอยู่กับสถานการณ์
ไม่ว่าจะอย่างไร เราจะเห็น Alice และ Bob ในตัวอย่างทั้งสาม
ที่เราจะพูดถึงในบทเรียนนี้ และเป็นครั้งคราว
ตลอดช่วงที่เหลือของซีรีส์ ผมจะแสดงความคิดเห็น
เกี่ยวกับ entanglement สักเล็กน้อยก่อนไปยังตัวอย่างทั้งสาม
ในบทเรียนที่สอง เราพบตัวอย่างนี้ของสถานะ entangled ของ qubit สองตัว
มันเป็นหนึ่งในสี่ Bell state และพูดได้ว่า
สถานะนี้เป็นตัวอย่างต้นแบบ
ของสถานะควอนตัมแบบ entangled
เรายังพบตัวอย่างนี้
ของสถานะความน่าจะเป็นของบิตสองตัว
มันคล้ายกับ
สถานะ entangled ในแง่หนึ่ง แต่มันไม่ใช่ entangled
entanglement เป็นปรากฏการณ์
ควอนตัมเฉพาะตัว
โดยพื้นฐานแล้วตามนิยาม
มีนิยามทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่แม่นยำว่า entanglement คืออะไร และโดยพื้นฐานแล้วนิยามนั้น
บอกว่า entanglement
คือความสัมพันธ์ควอนตัมที่ไม่ใช่แบบคลาสสิก
แต่นั่นไม่ได้ช่วยอะไรมากนัก
ในระดับสัญชาตญาณ มันเป็นนิยามของ entanglement ในแง่ของสิ่งที่ entanglement ไม่ใช่
และอาจด้วยเหตุผลนั้น
ที่จริงๆ แล้วมันค่อนข้างยากที่จะอธิบายว่า entanglement คืออะไรและอะไรทำให้มันพิเศษ
ในแง่ที่เข้าใจง่าย
เมื่อคนพยายาม
อธิบายว่า entanglement คืออะไรในแง่ที่เข้าใจง่าย คุณ
มักจะได้ยินคำอธิบายที่ไม่ได้
แยกแยะสองสถานะนี้
อย่างมีความหมาย คุณอาจได้ยินแนวคิด
ว่าถ้าคุณวัด qubit ตัวหนึ่งจากสองตัวที่ entangled กัน
สถานะของอีกตัวหนึ่ง
จะได้รับผลกระทบทันที หรือว่าสถานะของ qubit สองตัวไม่สามารถอธิบายแยกกันได้
หรือว่า qubit สองตัว
ยังคงรักษาความจำของกันและกัน หรือแม้แต่ว่า
พวกมันผูกพันทางอารมณ์ในทางใดทางหนึ่ง
แต่ทำไมคุณสมบัติเหล่านั้น
ถึงไม่จริงสำหรับสถานะนี้?
บิตสองตัวนี้เชื่อมโยงกันอย่างใกล้ชิด แต่ละตัวมีความจำ
ที่สมบูรณ์แบบของอีกตัวหนึ่งในความหมายตรงตัว แต่
มันไม่ใช่สถานะ entangled
วิธีหนึ่งที่จะอธิบายว่า
อะไรทำให้ entanglement พิเศษ และอะไรทำให้สถานะนี้
แตกต่างจากสถานะนี้มากคือการอธิบายว่าเรา
สามารถทำอะไรได้บ้างกับ entanglement
หรือสิ่งที่เราเห็นว่าเกิดขึ้น
เพราะ entanglement ที่เกินกว่าการตัดสินใจของเราเกี่ยวกับวิธีที่เราแสดง
ความรู้ของเราโดยใช้เวกเตอร์
ตัวอย่างทั้งสามที่
เราจะพูดถึงในบทเรียนนี้มีลักษณะแบบนี้ โดยแสดง
สิ่งที่เราทำได้ด้วย entanglement ที่เรา
ไม่สามารถทำได้ด้วยสถานะนี้
หรือกับสถานะที่มีความสัมพันธ์แบบคลาสสิกใดๆ
จริงๆ แล้ว เป็นเรื่องปกติมากในการศึกษาข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณที่เรามอง entanglement เป็นทรัพยากร
ที่สามารถใช้ทำ
งานต่างๆ ได้สำเร็จ
และเมื่อเราทำเช่นนั้น เรามองสถานะนี้เป็นตัวแทนของ
หนึ่งหน่วย entanglement
เราเรียกหน่วยของ
entanglement นี้ว่า e-bit โดย e ย่อมาจาก
entangled หรือ entanglement
จริงอยู่ว่ามันเป็น qubit สองตัว แต่ในฐานะปริมาณของ
entanglement มันคือหนึ่ง e-bit
คุณยังสามารถมองคู่ของ
บิตคลาสสิกธรรมดาในสถานะ
ความน่าจะเป็นแบบมีความสัมพันธ์กันจากก่อนหน้านี้เป็นทรัพยากรซึ่งเป็น
หนึ่งบิตของความสุ่มร่วม
มันมีประโยชน์มากใน
วิทยาการเข้ารหัสลับที่จะแชร์บิตสุ่มกับใครสักคน โดยสมมติ
ว่าไม่มีใครอื่นรู้ว่าบิตนั้นคืออะไร เพื่อที่จะ
ใช้เป็นกุญแจส่วนตัว
หรือเป็นส่วนหนึ่งของกุญแจส่วนตัว ตัวอย่างเช่น เพื่อการเข้ารหัส
แต่ในบทเรียนนี้ เราจะโฟกัสที่สถานะ entangled นี้ และ
สิ่งที่เราทำได้กับมัน
และเพื่อให้ชัดเจนเรื่องศัพท์ เมื่อเราบอกว่า Alice
และ Bob แชร์ e-bit หมายความว่า
Alice มี qubit ชื่อ A
Bob มี qubit ชื่อ B และคู่ A, B รวมกัน
อยู่ในสถานะ Phi plus
ไม่สำคัญว่าเราจะ
เลือกชื่ออะไรสำหรับ qubit สองตัว แน่นอน เรา
สามารถเลือกชื่ออื่นได้ แต่ตลอดบทเรียนนี้
เราจะใช้ชื่อเหล่านี้
เพื่อความชัดเจน ตัวอย่างแรกของบทเรียน
คือ quantum teleportation
ซึ่งต่อจากนี้ไปเราจะ
เรียกสั้นๆ ว่า teleportation เพื่อความกระชับ
Teleportation คือโปรโตคอลที่ช่วยให้ผู้ส่ง
ส่งข้อมูลควอนตัมไปยังผู้รับโดยใช้เพียง entanglement
และการสื่อสารแบบคลาสสิกเพื่อ
ทำการส่งนั้นให้สำเร็จ
มันไม่เกี่ยวอะไรเลยกับการตีความทั่วไป
ของคำว่า teleportation ในนิยายวิทยาศาสตร์ ซึ่ง
ก็คือสสารหายไป
จากที่หนึ่งและปรากฏขึ้นในอีกที่หนึ่ง
Quantum teleportation เป็นแค่ชื่อที่ตั้งขึ้นเพื่อให้นึกถึงภาพนั้นหรือเป็นอุปมาอุปไมย
สิ่งที่ถูก teleport คือ
ข้อมูลควอนตัม ไม่ใช่สสาร และมันเกิดขึ้น
ผ่านการส่งข้อมูลคลาสสิก
ร่วมกับ entanglement
เพื่อทำความเข้าใจ
ว่า teleportation ทำงานอย่างไร จะเป็นประโยชน์ที่จะเริ่ม
ด้วยการตั้งฉากก่อน
สิ่งที่เราจะทำคือจินตนาการสถานการณ์ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ Alice และ Bob และ
สถานการณ์นั้นเป็นดังนี้
Alice มี qubit ชื่อ Q ที่
เธออยากจะส่งให้ Bob หมายความว่าเธอ
ต้องการให้ Bob ถือในมือ
qubit ที่อยู่ในสถานะ
เดียวกันกับที่ Q อยู่ตอนเริ่มโปรโตคอล
กล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่ง เรากำลังพูดถึงปัญหาพื้นฐานของ
การส่งข้อมูลหรือการสื่อสาร
เรามีผู้ส่งชื่อ Alice
และผู้รับชื่อ Bob และ Alice ต้องการส่ง
ข้อมูลควอนตัมในรูปของ qubit ให้ Bob
แต่มีข้อจำกัด คือ Alice ไม่สามารถ
ส่ง Q ให้ Bob ได้โดยตรง สิ่งเดียวที่เธอทำได้คือส่งข้อมูลคลาสสิกให้ Bob
Alice และ Bob ยังมี
ทรัพยากรเพิ่มเติม คือพวกเขาแชร์ e-bit กัน
นั่นคือสถานการณ์ มัน
ง่ายที่จะจินตนาการสถานการณ์ที่ข้อจำกัดว่า
Alice ส่ง Q
ให้ Bob โดยตรงไม่ได้เป็นสิ่งที่สมเหตุสมผล
ถ้า Alice และ Bob อยู่
คนละทวีป หรือถ้า Alice ไม่รู้
ตำแหน่งที่แน่นอนของ Bob การส่ง qubit โดยตรง
น่าจะค่อนข้างท้าทาย
แต่การสื่อสารแบบคลาสสิก
ไม่เพียงแต่เป็นไปได้ แต่ยังถูกมาก
ภายใต้สถานการณ์เหล่านั้น
ตอนนี้ อาจมีคนถามว่า Alice และ Bob สามารถทำงานนี้ได้โดยไม่ต้องใช้ e-bit ร่วมกันหรือเปล่า
กล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่ง มี
ทางไหนที่จะส่ง qubit โดยใช้การสื่อสาร
คลาสสิกอย่างเดียวหรือเปล่า?
คำตอบคือไม่ได้ ไม่สามารถส่งข้อมูลควอนตัมโดยใช้การสื่อสารคลาสสิกอย่างเดียวได้ และนั่นไม่ยากที่จะพิสูจน์
โดยใช้ทฤษฎีข้อมูลควอนตัม
พื้นฐานบางอย่าง ซึ่งเราจะเห็น
ในหน่วยที่สามของซีรีส์
ตอนนี้ วิธีคิดที่ใช้
สัญชาตญาณได้คือคิดถึงทฤษฎีบทห้ามโคลน
ลองจินตนาการว่ามีวิธี
ส่งข้อมูลควอนตัมโดยใช้การสื่อสารคลาสสิกอย่างเดียว
แต่การสื่อสารคลาสสิก
สามารถถูกคัดลอกและกระจายได้ง่าย นั่นหมายความว่า
การสื่อสารคลาสสิก
สามารถกระจายไปยัง
ผู้รับสองคน Bob และ Charlie สมมติ
ถ้าทั้งคู่ได้รับ
ข้อมูลคลาสสิกเดียวกันจาก Alice แล้ว
พวกเขาทั้งคู่จะได้ Q หรือเปล่า?
นั่นจะบอกเป็นนัยว่าเราโคลน Q แต่เรารู้ว่ามันเป็นไปไม่ได้
เป็นเรื่องนอกเรื่องนิดนึง
ลองสังเกตว่าแน่นอนมันเป็นไปได้ที่จะอธิบาย
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมโดยใช้ข้อมูลคลาสสิก
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ทุกตัวที่คุณเห็นในซีรีส์กำลังถูกอธิบายให้คุณ
โดยใช้ข้อมูลคลาสสิกที่ถูกส่งไปยัง
อุปกรณ์ที่คุณกำลังดู
โดยทั่วไป เราสามารถจินตนาการ
การอธิบายว่าสถานะ Q เป็นอะไรโดยใช้บิตคลาสสิก
อาจจะมีความแม่นยำระดับหนึ่ง
แต่นั่นไม่ใช่การสื่อสารควอนตัม นั่นแค่อธิบาย
สถานะควอนตัมในรูปเวกเตอร์ และเราจะกลับมาที่
ความแตกต่างระหว่างมัน
ในอีกสักครู่
กลับมาที่สถานการณ์ และทำงานภายใต้
สมมติฐานว่า Alice และ Bob แชร์ e-bit กัน เราจะ
เห็นว่า Alice และ Bob
มีทุกอย่างที่ต้องการ
เพื่อทำงานนี้ให้สำเร็จ และนั่นคือสิ่งที่โปรโตคอล quantum
teleportation ทำ โดยเฉพาะการใช้บิตคลาสสิก
สองบิตในการสื่อสาร
ก่อนที่จะลงรายละเอียด
เหล่านี้ ให้ผมพูดสั้นๆ สักนิด
เพื่อให้แน่ใจว่าสมมติฐานชัดเจน
ประการแรก เราสมมติ
ว่าสถานะของ Q ไม่เป็นที่รู้สำหรับ Alice และ
Bob ดังนั้นโดยเฉพาะ
Alice ไม่สามารถส่งคำอธิบาย
ของสถานะ Q ให้ Bob ได้เพราะเธอไม่รู้มันโดยทั่วไป
เรายังต้องพิจารณาความเป็นไปได้ที่ Q มีความสัมพันธ์กับระบบอื่น รวมถึงความเป็นไปได้
ที่มัน entangled
กับระบบอื่น และ
การส่ง qubit นี้ไปยัง Bob ต้องรักษาความสัมพันธ์เหล่านั้นไว้
สุดท้าย ผมพูดถึง
ทฤษฎีบทห้ามโคลนเมื่อผมพูดถึง
การพยายามสื่อสาร qubit แบบคลาสสิก แต่
มีความเชื่อมโยงอีกอย่างตรงนี้
กับทฤษฎีบทห้ามโคลน คือถ้า Bob
ได้รับการส่ง qubit Q นี้จาก Alice
เธอต้องไม่มีมันอีกต่อไป
เพราะ Q ไม่สามารถถูกโคลนได้ และนั่นเป็นสิ่งที่ต้องจำไว้
เมื่อเราพิจารณาโปรโตคอล teleportation
โปรโตคอล teleportation
สามารถอธิบายได้อย่างง่ายและตรงไปตรงมาด้วยแผนภาพ quantum circuit อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
มันถูกจัดรูปแบบเล็กน้อย
โดยแสดงการแบ่งแยกระหว่างส่วนของ Alice และส่วนของ Bob แต่นอกจากนั้น มันเป็นแค่
แผนภาพ quantum circuit
ทุกอย่างเหนือเส้นประ
แทนการกระทำของ Alice และทุกอย่างด้านล่าง
แทนการกระทำของ Bob
เวลาไปจากซ้ายไปขวาเหมือนเดิม และเราเห็นว่าเราเริ่ม
ด้วย qubit สองตัวนี้อยู่ในสถานะ Phi plus
นี่คือ e-bit
ที่ Alice และ Bob เริ่มต้นด้วย
เราสามารถติดป้ายกำกับบน qubit เพื่อให้ชัดว่าตัวไหนเป็น
ตัวไหน นี่คือ qubit A และนี่คือ qubit
B ที่ประกอบเป็น e-bit
และนี่คือ qubit Q ที่
Alice ต้องการส่งให้ Bob
ตรงนี้เราตั้งสมมติฐานว่า
สถานะของ qubit Q คือ Psi แต่อีกสักครู่เราจะพิจารณาความเป็นไปได้
ที่ Q จะ entangled
กับระบบอื่น และสิ่งที่แผนภาพอ้างเพราะเราเขียน psi ตรงนี้ด้านล่าง
คือ circuit นี้
ส่งสถานะ psi ที่เรามี
ตรงนี้ในส่วนของ Alice ลงมาตรงนี้ที่ส่วนของ Bob ได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
การสื่อสารเดียว
ที่ข้ามเส้นแบ่งระหว่าง
Alice และ Bob คือบิตคลาสสิก
สองบิตที่แสดงด้วยเส้นคู่ตรงนี้
มาย่อแผนภาพนี้
ลงสักหน่อยเพื่อให้มีพื้นที่มากขึ้น แล้วมาตรวจสอบ
circuit อย่างใกล้ชิด
ผมได้อธิบาย
เงื่อนไขเริ่มต้นไปแล้ว แต่เพื่อสรุปอีกครั้ง Alice ถือ qubit A
และ Bob ถือ qubit B
โดย A และ B รวมกัน
อยู่ในสถานะ Phi plus นั่นคือความหมายของการแชร์ e-bit
Alice ยังมี qubit Q ที่เธอต้องการส่งให้ Bob และเรากำลังพิจารณากรณีที่ Q อยู่ในสถานะควอนตัมใดๆ Psi
ตอนนี้ เราไม่รู้อะไร
เกี่ยวกับว่า Alice และ Bob ได้ e-bit นี้มาอย่างไร
อาจเป็นว่าพวกเขา
มีมันมานานแล้ว อาจสร้างมันเมื่อนานมาแล้วตอนที่อยู่ในสถานที่เดียวกัน
และเก็บมันไว้
สำหรับโอกาสนี้ แต่รายละเอียดเหล่านั้นไม่เกี่ยวข้องตรงนี้
ขั้นตอนที่เกิดขึ้นถัดไป ซึ่งเป็นตัวแทนของ
โปรโตคอล teleportation เองเป็นดังนี้ และเพื่อให้ชัดเจน
นี่คือขั้นตอนที่
แผนภาพอธิบาย และเราจะ
เขียนมันเป็นคำพูดเพื่อให้ชัดว่า
แผนภาพแสดงอะไร
ก่อนอื่น Alice ทำ
การดำเนินการ controlled-NOT โดยที่ qubit Q ที่
เธอต้องการส่งให้ Bob เป็นตัวควบคุม และ
qubit A เป็นเป้าหมาย
ขั้นตอนถัดไปคือเธอ
ทำการดำเนินการ Hadamard บน Q แล้วเธอวัด
qubit สองตัวที่เธอถือ
A และ Q ด้วย
การวัดแบบ standard basis และให้ตัว a พิมพ์เล็กเป็นผลลัพธ์ของการวัด qubit A
และให้ตัว b พิมพ์เล็กเป็นผลลัพธ์ของการวัด qubit Q
จากนั้น Alice ส่งบิต
คลาสสิกสองตัวนั้นให้ Bob และนี่คือการสื่อสารเดียวที่เกี่ยวข้องในโปรโตคอลนี้ และแสดงในแผนภาพ
จากการที่บิตสองตัวนี้
ข้ามเส้นประระหว่าง Alice และ Bob
ซึ่งคุณอาจมองว่าแทน
ระยะทางที่แยกพวกเขาออกจากกัน
หลังจาก Bob ได้รับบิต
a และ b เขาทำสองสิ่ง
ก่อน ถ้า a เท่ากับหนึ่ง เขาจะทำการดำเนินการ X
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ NOT gate บน qubit B ของเขา
และถ้า a เท่ากับศูนย์ เขาก็ไม่ทำอะไร
และในทำนองเดียวกัน
ถ้า b เท่ากับหนึ่ง Bob จะทำการดำเนินการ Z
หรือ Z-gate หรือการพลิกเฟส
บน qubit b เช่นกัน และ
เช่นเดิม ถ้า b เท่ากับศูนย์ เขาก็ไม่ทำอะไร
ทั้งหมดนี้แสดงในรูปภาพที่เรามี controlled-X
และ controlled-Z gate โดยที่ตัวควบคุมคือ
บิตคลาสสิกสองตัว
คุณไม่จำเป็นต้องมอง gate เหล่านี้เป็น control gate
ถ้าไม่อยาก นี่เป็นแค่วิธีที่สะดวกในการ
แสดงสิ่งที่เราต้องการ
ในรูปแบบแผนภาพ circuit ประเด็นคือ Bob ใช้
X-gate กับ qubit b ถ้า a เท่ากับหนึ่ง แล้ว
เขาใช้ Z-gate
กับ qubit b ถ้า B เท่ากับหนึ่ง
และเพื่อความสะดวกในภายหลัง เราสามารถเขียนอย่างชัดเจน
การดำเนินการรวมที่ Bob ทำบน qubit b ของเขา
ขึ้นอยู่กับบิตคลาสสิก
ที่ Alice ส่งมา
นั่นคือโปรโตคอล teleportation ค่อนข้างง่ายจริงๆ
ความจริงที่ว่ามันทำงานได้จริงเป็นอีกเรื่องหนึ่ง
และถึงแม้การวิเคราะห์
จะไม่ซับซ้อนมาก
คุณไม่ควรรู้สึกว่าพลาดอะไรไปถ้าคุณไม่เห็นทันทีว่าทำไมมันถึงทำงานได้
นั่นคือเหตุผลที่เรา
ต้องวิเคราะห์ และนั่นคือสิ่งที่เราจะทำต่อไป
เพื่อวิเคราะห์โปรโตคอล teleportation เราจะทำทีละขั้นตอนเพื่อดูว่าสถานะ
ของ qubit สามตัวเป็นอย่างไรในแต่ละช่วงเวลา
เราจะพิจารณา
กรณีแรกที่ qubit บนสุดอยู่ในสถานะ AlphaZero บวก beta one โดย alpha และ beta
เป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อนใดๆ
ที่ทำให้เวกเตอร์นี้
เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
นี่คือ qubit Q ที่
Alice กำลังพยายามส่ง แต่เราไม่สนใจจริงๆ ว่ามัน
ถูกเรียกว่าอะไรตอนนี้
อีกสักครู่ เราจะ
ดูสถานการณ์ที่ qubit นี้
entangled กับระบบอื่น แต่นี่เป็นจุดเริ่มต้นที่ดี
เพื่อให้สิ่งต่างๆ ง่ายขึ้น
และเพื่อดูว่าการวิเคราะห์
ทำงานอย่างไรได้ชัดเจนขึ้น
ถ้าเราพิจารณาสถานะของ
qubit สามตัวรวมกันตรงจุดเริ่มต้น เราจะเห็น
ว่าสถานะนี้มีรูปแบบที่เห็นตรงนี้
qubit สองตัวแรก
อยู่ในสถานะ Phi plus qubit ตัวที่สามคือตัวบนสุด
ตามระเบียบ
ของการเรียงลำดับ qubit ที่ผม
อธิบายในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า ดังนั้นเราจึงหา tensor product เพื่อให้ได้สถานะของ
qubit สามตัวรวมกัน
เราสามารถขยายนิพจน์นี้
โดยแทนนิยามของสถานะ Phi plus ก่อน แล้วคำนวณ tensor product
แล้วเราจะได้สถานะ
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
ไม่ใช่กลยุทธ์ที่ดีที่สุดเสมอไป
ที่จะขยายเวกเตอร์แบบนี้ออกทั้งหมด โดยทั่วไปควรรอจนกว่า
จะมีเหตุผลดีๆ ที่จะทำ
แต่ตรงนี้เรามีเหตุผล ซึ่งก็คือเราต้องการ
คำนวณผลของ controlled NOT gate นี้ และเมื่อเขียนสถานะในรูปแบบนี้
เราสามารถทำได้ง่ายมาก
และโดยเฉพาะ นี่คือ
สถานะของ qubit สามตัวหลังจากใช้ controlled NOT gate
qubit ตัวที่สามเป็น qubit ควบคุมเพราะมันเป็นตัวที่
อยู่บนสุดตามระเบียบของเรา และ qubit ตัวที่สอง
ซึ่งเป็นตัวกลาง
เป็นเป้าหมาย ดังนั้นเราแค่
ทำตาม ket ตามลำดับ ถ้าบิตที่สามเป็น
ศูนย์ ไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้น
และถ้าบิตที่สามเป็นหนึ่ง
เราก็พลิกบิตที่สอง
จากนั้นเราทำ Hadamard
gate บน qubit ตัวที่สาม เราสามารถเขียนเวกเตอร์
ผลลัพธ์อย่างที่เห็น
ตรงนี้ โดยแทนที่สถานะ
บวก และ ลบ แทนสถานะศูนย์และหนึ่ง
และถ้าเราต้องการ
พื้นที่พอที่จะขยายมันออก เราจะต้องย่อ
มันลงสักหน่อย แล้วตอนนี้ โดยแทนที่สถานะ
บวกและลบ
ด้วยนิยามของมัน
นำรากที่สองของสองเข้าไปในตัวหาร เราจะได้สถานะที่เห็นตรงนี้
และเมื่อขยายมันออก เราจะได้สถานะที่เห็นตรงนี้
นั่นคือสถานะของ qubit สามตัวหลังจาก Alice ทำการดำเนินการสองอย่างของเธอ
จากนั้น Alice วัด
และถ้าเราต้องการวิเคราะห์การวัด สิ่งที่เราทำคือแยก standard basis vector
สำหรับระบบที่ถูกวัด
เหมือนที่เราพูดถึงในบทเรียนที่สอง และถ้าเราทำในกรณีนี้ นี่คือสิ่งที่เราได้
และถ้าคุณดู
นิพจน์นั้นสักครู่ มันอาจดูแปลกๆ เพราะตอนนี้ดูเหมือนว่า qubit ตัวแรก
ซึ่งเป็น qubit ด้านล่าง
ดูเหมือนขึ้นอยู่กับ alpha และ beta ถึงแม้ว่า
ตอนนี้ยังไม่มีการสื่อสารข้ามเส้นประ
แต่นั่นเป็นแค่ภาพลวง จำไว้ว่าสเกลาร์ลอย
ผ่าน tensor product ได้อย่างอิสระ ดังนั้นไม่มีความหมายจริงๆ
ที่ alpha และ beta
เชื่อมโยงกับ qubit ตัวแรก
สิ่งที่เราทำจริงๆ
ตรงนี้คือใช้วงเล็บตาม
ความเป็นเส้นตรงหลายตัวแปรของ tensor product
อย่างไรก็ตาม นั่นคือรูปแบบที่เราต้องการเพื่อดูว่าการวัดทำอะไร และเราเห็น
สิ่งที่น่าสนใจได้ทันที
คือความน่าจะเป็นของผลลัพธ์การวัดสี่แบบที่เป็นไปได้จะกระจายสม่ำเสมอเสมอ
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะวัดได้แต่ละ
คู่ผลลัพธ์คือหนึ่งในสี่ ดังนั้นโดยเฉพาะ
ไม่มีการขึ้นอยู่กับ
alpha และ beta เลย
เราเห็นได้ในแต่ละกรณีโดยคำนวณค่าบรรทัดฐานยูคลิดยกกำลังสองของ
เวกเตอร์ใดก็ตามที่ถูก tensor กับ standard basis
vector ที่เราแยกออกมา
และในแต่ละกรณีเราได้หนึ่งในสี่ ซึ่งได้จากการยกกำลังสองของหนึ่งในสองคูณค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของ alpha
บวกค่าสัมบูรณ์
ยกกำลังสองของ beta ซึ่งเท่ากับหนึ่ง ดังนั้นเราจึงได้หนึ่งในสี่ในทุกกรณี
ที่จริงแล้วมันสำคัญมาก
ที่ความน่าจะเป็นของผลลัพธ์ต่างๆ ไม่ขึ้นอยู่กับ qubit ที่
Alice ต้องการส่งเลย
เราไม่สามารถมีสถานะใดๆ เข้ามาตรงนี้ด้านบนแล้วออกไปด้านล่าง และในขณะเดียวกันการวัดเผย
ข้อมูลเกี่ยวกับสถานะนั้น
ถ้าคุณต้องการได้ข้อมูลเกี่ยวกับสถานะควอนตัมใดๆ คุณจะต้องรบกวน
สถานะนั้นโดยทั่วไป
นี่คือตารางที่อธิบายไม่เพียงแค่ความน่าจะเป็น
ของผลลัพธ์ต่างๆ แต่ยังรวมถึงสถานะของ
qubit สามตัวรวมกัน
ที่ขึ้นอยู่กับผลลัพธ์
การวัดแต่ละแบบ
เราได้สิ่งนี้จากการนอร์มัลไลซ์เวกเตอร์ที่ถูก tensor กับ standard basis state ต่างๆ แต่นั่นง่ายในกรณีนี้
เราแค่ตัดตัวคูณหนึ่งในสองออกเพื่อให้ได้เวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วย
ดังนั้น สิ่งที่เรามีทันที
หลังจาก Alice วัดคือ Alice มีบิตสุ่มสม่ำเสมอ
สองตัวและนั่นคือทั้งหมด
โดยเฉพาะ เธอไม่มี
สถานะเดิมอีกต่อไป และเธอไม่มี
ข้อมูลอะไรเกี่ยวกับมัน เธอมีแค่บิตสุ่ม
สถานะของ Bob ตอนนี้
ขึ้นอยู่กับ alpha และ beta รวมถึงผลลัพธ์การวัดด้วย
ถ้าเราจินตนาการชั่วขณะ
ว่า Alice ยังไม่ได้ส่งผลลัพธ์การวัด
ดังนั้น Bob ไม่รู้ว่าผลลัพธ์การวัดคืออะไร
เขาจะไม่สามารถ
ได้ข้อมูลอะไรเกี่ยวกับ alpha และ beta
จากการวัด qubit ของเขา
ความเป็นไปได้สี่แบบ
ที่เรามีตรงนี้ถูกสับเปลี่ยนมากพอที่จะมั่นใจได้ว่าไม่มีข้อมูล
เกี่ยวกับ alpha และ beta
จะได้จาก
การวัดเลย นั่นต้องเป็นจริงในระดับสัญชาตญาณเพราะไม่เช่นนั้นเราจะมี
การสื่อสารเร็วกว่าแสง
Alice ไม่สามารถ
ส่งข้อมูลถึง Bob โดยไม่ส่งอะไรเลยแน่นอน แต่แน่นอน Alice
ส่งผลลัพธ์การวัด
ให้ Bob ดังนั้นมาขยายตารางเพื่อดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อ
Bob ทำการดำเนินการของเขา
ในคอลัมน์ตรงนี้ เรามีการดำเนินการต่างๆ ที่ Bob ทำสำหรับแต่ละผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้
ของการวัด
อย่างที่เราสังเกตก่อนหน้า
และถ้าเราไปทีละอย่างแล้วใช้การดำเนินการ
นั้นกับ qubit ของ Bob ซึ่งเป็นตัวแรก B
เราจะเห็นว่าได้ผลลัพธ์
เดียวกันในทั้งสี่กรณี และผลลัพธ์นั้นคือสถานะเดิม
สถานะเดิมของ qubit Q ถูก teleport ไปยัง B สำเร็จแล้ว
ถ้า Bob ต้องการเปลี่ยนชื่อ qubit ของเขาแล้วเรียกว่า Q ตอนนี้ เขาก็ทำได้เลย แต่ประเด็นคือตอนนี้
เขาถือสถานะเดิม
ที่ Alice มี และแน่นอนโดยจำเป็น Alice ไม่มีมันอีกต่อไป
สังเกตด้วยว่า e-bit
ถูกใช้หมดไปผ่านกระบวนการนี้
teleportation มีค่าใช้จ่าย
และค่าใช้จ่ายคือหนึ่ง e-bit และบิตคลาสสิกสองบิตของการสื่อสาร และเมื่อโปรโตคอล
จบลง e-bit ก็หมดไป
ตอนนี้เราได้พิสูจน์แล้วว่า
โปรโตคอล teleportation ทำงานถูกต้องภายใต้สมมติฐานว่า qubit บนสุดอยู่ในสถานะควอนตัม
ในรูปแบบ alpha คูณ ket
ศูนย์ บวก beta คูณ ket หนึ่ง
แต่จะเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้า
qubit บนสุด entangled กับระบบอื่น เช่น
qubit เพิ่มเติมอีกตัว
อย่างที่เห็นบนหน้าจอ? เราอาจต้องการใช้ teleportation
ภายใต้สถานการณ์เช่นนั้น
บางที Alice และ Bob อาจ
วางแผนจะทำ teleportation 100 ครั้ง เพื่อให้ Alice ส่ง
รีจิสเตอร์ควอนตัม 100 qubit
ให้ Bob ทีละ qubit
หรือบางที qubit เพิ่มเติม
เหล่านี้ไม่ได้อยู่ในครอบครองของ Alice เลย
และคนอื่นมีมัน บางที Alice ไม่รู้ด้วยซ้ำ
ว่ามันมีอยู่
คำถามคือ teleportation
ยังทำงานได้หรือเปล่าถึงแม้ qubit ที่ถูก teleport จะ entangled กับระบบอื่น?
ตรงนี้ สถานะของ qubit Q รวมกับระบบ
เพิ่มเติมที่เราพิจารณาแสดงอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ด้านบน
โดยที่ gamma ศูนย์ และ
gamma หนึ่ง เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยที่แทนสถานะควอนตัม
ของระบบเพิ่มเติมนี้
เราสามารถเขียนสถานะใดๆ ของระบบรวมในรูปแบบนี้ได้เสมอ
เราไม่จำเป็นต้องใช้
alpha และ beta จริงๆ แต่ถ้าเรารวมมันไว้
เราก็สามารถให้ gamma ศูนย์ และ gamma หนึ่ง เป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยได้
และนั่นจะทำให้
เชื่อมโยงกับกรณีที่ง่ายกว่าที่เราพิจารณาไปแล้วได้ชัดเจนขึ้น
เราสามารถวิเคราะห์
คล้ายกับที่เราทำไปแล้ว แต่ที่เราเก็บข้อมูล
ของระบบเพิ่มเติมนี้ด้วย
มันยุ่งขึ้นหน่อยเพราะมีระบบเพิ่มเติม แต่
แนวคิดเหมือนกันเป๊ะ นี่คือสรุปสั้นๆ
นี่คือสถานะเริ่มต้น นี่คือสถานะหลังจาก
controlled NOT gate
และนี่คือสถานะหลังจาก
การดำเนินการ Hadamard
ถ้าเราขยายสิ่งเหล่านี้
ออก เราสามารถแสดงสถานะนั้นอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
นั่นคือสถานะทันที
ก่อนการวัดของ Alice และถ้าเราไล่ดู
ความเป็นไปได้เหมือนเดิม
และเราพิจารณาว่า
เกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อ Bob ใช้การดำเนินการที่เขาควรจะใช้
เราก็จะพบว่า
สถานะที่ถูกต้องออกมาจริง และโปรโตคอลทำงานตามที่คาดไว้
ในตารางนี้ เราใช้ตัวอักษร R เพื่อ
อ้างถึงระบบเพิ่มเติมนี้ และคุณจะเห็นว่าเรา
ใช้เทคนิคง่ายๆ
คือตัดสินใจว่าเราอยากจะ อย่างน้อยชั่วขณะ เรียงลำดับ
ระบบเป็น B, R, A, Q
เพราะนั่นสะดวกกว่าสำหรับการเขียนสถานะตรงนี้
ตามแผนภาพ ระบบควรจะ
เรียงลำดับเป็น B, A, Q, R
แต่ตราบใดที่เราทำให้ชัดเจน เราสามารถเลือก
ลำดับอื่นที่สะดวกกว่าได้
สรุปสั้นๆ ทุกอย่างที่เกิดขึ้นในการวิเคราะห์นี้เหมือนกับ
สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นในการวิเคราะห์ที่ง่ายกว่า
แต่เราบังเอิญมี
เวกเตอร์เพิ่มเติม gamma ศูนย์ และ gamma หนึ่ง
ที่ตามมาด้วยโดยพื้นฐาน
เรามี gamma ศูนย์ เสมอ
เมื่อมีตัวคูณ alpha และ gamma หนึ่ง เมื่อ
มีตัวคูณ beta และท้ายที่สุด
ทุกอย่างก็ออกมาถูกต้อง
จริงๆ แล้วนี่ไม่น่าแปลกใจเลย เรามีกระบวนการทางกายภาพที่ทำหน้าที่เหมือนการดำเนินการเอกลักษณ์
บน qubit
ในสถานะควอนตัมใดๆ และมีทางเดียวเท่านั้น
ที่จะเกิดขึ้นได้ คือการดำเนินการ
นั้นต้องเป็นการดำเนินการเอกลักษณ์
นั่นอธิบายง่ายกว่าเล็กน้อยโดยใช้สูตรทั่วไป
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม แต่ประเด็นคือว่าโดยความเป็นเส้นตรง
เราไม่จำเป็นต้องวิเคราะห์เพิ่มเติมนี้จริงๆ
เมื่อเรารู้ว่า
teleportation ทำงานถูกต้องสำหรับ qubit เดี่ยวแบบแยกเดี่ยว เราสรุปได้ว่ามี
สิ่งเดียวที่เป็นไปได้
ที่อธิบายสิ่งที่โปรโตคอลทำ คือมันดำเนินการ
เอกลักษณ์ที่ qubit เข้ามาตรงนี้
แล้วออกไปตรงนี้ ทำหน้าที่เหมือนช่องทางควอนตัม
ที่สมบูรณ์แบบไม่มีสัญญาณรบกวน
พูดสั้นๆ สักนิด
เกี่ยวกับ teleportation ก่อนไปยัง
ตัวอย่างที่สองของบทเรียน ซึ่งก็คือ superdense coding
ประการแรก ผมคิดว่าสิ่งสำคัญคือต้องชี้แจงว่า teleportation ไม่ใช่การประยุกต์ใช้ข้อมูลควอนตัม มันเป็นโปรโตคอล
และโดยเฉพาะมันเป็น
โปรโตคอลสำหรับการสื่อสารควอนตัม
เพื่อให้ teleportation
อย่างที่ผมอธิบายมีประโยชน์ ต้องมีเหตุผลบางอย่างในการสื่อสารควอนตัม
ประการที่สอง เป็นเรื่องสมเหตุสมผลที่จะคาดการณ์ว่า teleportation อาจ
กลายเป็นวิธีมาตรฐานสักวัน
ในการสื่อสารข้อมูลควอนตัม และโดยเฉพาะกระบวนการที่เรียกว่า entanglement distillation
อาจถูกใช้
เป็นวิธีในการสื่อสาร qubit อย่างน่าเชื่อถือ ถ้า Alice และ Bob รู้ว่าพวกเขา
จะต้องสื่อสารข้อมูลควอนตัม หรือ
มีความจำเป็นต้องสื่อสาร
ข้อมูลควอนตัม กระบวนการ entanglement distillation
สามารถใช้แปลง e-bit ที่มีสัญญาณรบกวนจำนวนมาก
เป็น e-bit คุณภาพสูง
จำนวนน้อยกว่า ที่สามารถใช้สำหรับ teleportation ที่ไม่มีหรือเกือบไม่มีสัญญาณรบกวน
แนวคิดคือกระบวนการ
entanglement distillation ไม่ละเอียดอ่อนมากนัก เรายอมรับความสูญเสียได้ และ
ถ้ามันไม่สำเร็จ
เราก็แค่ลองอีกครั้ง ในขณะที่ qubit จริงที่
เราต้องการสื่อสารอาจถือว่ามีค่ามากกว่ามาก
แน่นอน นี่เป็นแค่การคาดการณ์ แต่ประเด็นคือไม่ยากที่จะสมมติสถานการณ์
ที่ teleportation
อาจเป็นวิธีที่ใช้งานได้จริง
ในการสื่อสาร qubit
และประเด็นสุดท้าย
เกี่ยวกับ teleportation คือแนวคิดเบื้องหลัง teleportation และวิธีที่มันทำงาน
เป็นพื้นฐานมาก
ในข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ teleportation เป็นรากฐานสำคัญของทฤษฎีข้อมูลควอนตัม
และรูปแบบต่างๆ
ของแนวคิดนี้ก็มักจะ
ปรากฏขึ้น เป็นแค่ตัวอย่างหนึ่ง มีข้อเสนอสำหรับ
การดำเนินการ quantum gate ต่างๆ
โดยใช้ teleportation แต่
ที่ใช้สถานะเริ่มต้นและการวัดที่ต่างกัน
เพื่อให้ผลลัพธ์
เป็นการใช้การดำเนินการที่เลือก
แทนที่จะเป็นการสื่อสาร
ตัวอย่างถัดไปคือ superdense coding
เช่นเดียวกับ quantum teleportation
superdense coding เป็นโปรโตคอล และสิ่งที่มันทำได้นั้นเสริมกับ teleportation
ในขณะที่ teleportation ช่วยให้
ส่ง qubit หนึ่งตัวโดยใช้ e-bit และบิตคลาสสิก
สองบิตในการสื่อสาร
superdense coding ช่วยให้
ส่งบิตคลาสสิกสองบิตโดยใช้
e-bit และ qubit หนึ่งตัวของการสื่อสารควอนตัม
สรุปสั้นๆ superdense coding ช่วยให้ส่ง
ข้อมูลคลาสสิกได้ และเหตุผลที่เรียกว่า
superdense coding
ก็เพราะมันช่วยให้ยัดบิต
คลาสสิกสองบิตเข้าไปใน qubit เดียวได้
แต่เราต้องเผา e-bit
เพื่อทำสิ่งนี้
นี่คือคำอธิบายที่ชัดเจน
กว่าของการตั้งค่า
อีกครั้ง เรามี Alice และ Bob โดย Alice เป็นผู้ส่ง
และ Bob เป็นผู้รับ และคราวนี้ Alice มีบิตคลาสสิกสองตัว
ที่เธอต้องการส่งให้ Bob
Alice สามารถส่ง qubit เดียวให้ Bob ได้ และ Alice กับ Bob แชร์
e-bit ที่สามารถใช้ช่วยทำงานให้สำเร็จ
ซึ่งก็คือการที่ Bob ได้รับ
บิตคลาสสิกสองตัว
ตอนนี้ มีแง่หนึ่งที่งานนี้อาจดูน่าสนใจน้อยกว่างานที่
teleportation ทำได้
โดยเฉพาะถ้าเรามอง
ว่าการส่ง qubit ยากกว่า
หรือท้าทายกว่าการส่งบิตคลาสสิกมาก
ซึ่งเป็นมุมมองที่สมเหตุสมผล แต่มันน่าสนใจจริงๆ ที่มันเป็นไปได้
เหตุผลหนึ่งที่มันน่าสนใจ
คือจริงๆ แล้วมันเป็นไปไม่ได้ที่จะทำ
งานส่งบิตคลาสสิกสองบิต
โดยใช้ qubit เดียวโดยไม่
ใช้ e-bit
เรารู้สิ่งนี้เพราะทฤษฎีบทที่มีชื่อเสียงที่เรียกว่าทฤษฎีบท Holevo
ทฤษฎีบท Holevo นั้น
กว้างกว่านี้ และข้อความที่แม่นยำ
ของทฤษฎีบท Holevo ค่อนข้างเป็นเทคนิคและ
ต้องการคำอธิบายเพิ่มเติม
แต่ผลที่ตามมาอย่างหนึ่ง
คือคุณไม่สามารถส่งบิตคลาสสิก
จำนวนใดๆ โดยใช้ qubit ที่น้อยกว่า
ของการสื่อสารควอนตัมเพียงอย่างเดียว
ถ้าคุณต้องการส่งบิตคลาสสิกสองบิตอย่าง
น่าเชื่อถือโดยใช้ qubit และไม่มี
e-bit ให้ใช้
คุณจะต้องส่ง qubit สองตัว ดังนั้นมันอาจจะเก็บบิตที่คุณต้องการส่งไว้เลยก็ได้
อีกเหตุผลหนึ่งที่ superdense
coding น่าสนใจคือเพราะความสัมพันธ์
เสริมที่ใกล้ชิดกับ teleportation และ
เราจะกลับมาที่เรื่องนี้
อีกสักครู่ นี่คือคำอธิบาย quantum circuit ของโปรโตคอล superdense coding
สำหรับอันนี้ ผม
จะไม่ลิสต์ขั้นตอนทั้งหมด แต่จะใช้คำอธิบายแผนภาพ circuit แทน
อย่างที่เห็น เราอีกครั้ง
มี Alice และ Bob โดย Alice อยู่ด้านบน
และ Bob อยู่ด้านล่าง
นี่คือ e-bit ที่
ถูกแชร์ระหว่าง Alice และ Bob ในตอนแรก ซึ่งได้
ถูกสร้างขึ้นก่อนที่โปรโตคอลจะทำงาน
Alice มีบิตคลาสสิกสองตัว A และ B ที่เห็นตรงนี้ด้านบน
และผ่านโปรโตคอลที่ circuit อธิบาย
บิตคลาสสิกสองตัวนี้
จะไปอยู่ในมือของ Bob
มี qubit แค่ตัวเดียว
ที่ข้ามเส้นแบ่งระหว่าง Alice และ Bob และแน่นอนไม่มี
บิตคลาสสิกถูกส่ง
การส่งบิตคลาสสิก
สองตัวนั้นคือจุดประสงค์ของโปรโตคอล
คุณจะสังเกตด้วยว่ามัน
ใช้ส่วนประกอบเดียวกันกับที่ใช้ใน teleportation เรามี controlled NOT
gate, Hadamard gate
และ Z กับ X-gate
ที่ถูกควบคุมด้วยบิตคลาสสิก
แต่มันถูกจัดเรียงต่างกัน ดังนั้นไปต่อที่
การวิเคราะห์เพื่อดูว่ามันทำงานอย่างไร
เพื่อวิเคราะห์ว่า superdense coding ทำงานอย่างไร มาเริ่มด้วยการเขียน
Bell basis ซึ่งเป็นหัวใจของ
การวิเคราะห์
สิ่งที่เราจะทำคือ
ดูผลของการกระทำของ Alice
ต่อสถานะ Phi plus ก่อน และสิ่งที่เราจะเห็นคือ
Alice เปลี่ยน
สถานะ Phi plus นี้ให้เป็น
หนึ่งในสี่ Bell state ขึ้นอยู่กับบิต
ที่เธอต้องการส่ง
มาเขียนตารางเพื่อให้เราติดตาม
สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นได้
ก่อน ถ้า A และ B เป็นศูนย์ทั้งคู่ ทั้ง Z-gate และ
X-gate ก็ไม่ถูกใช้ ดังนั้นการกระทำของ Alice ไม่ทำอะไร
ซึ่งหมายความว่า Phi
plus ถูกแมปไปเป็น Phi plus
เราสามารถแสดงเป็นสมการอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ด้วย
ไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้นกับ qubit ของ Alice และไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้นกับ qubit ของ Bob
และการไม่ทำอะไรแสดงด้วย
เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์
ทีนี้ จะเกิดอะไรขึ้นถ้า A เท่ากับศูนย์ และ B เท่ากับหนึ่ง?
เพราะ B เท่ากับหนึ่ง เราจึงใช้ Z-gate และ
เราไม่ใช้ X-gate เพราะ A เท่ากับศูนย์
และเราเห็นว่าผลรวมคือ Alice ทำ Z-gate
Alice อยู่ทางขวา
เพราะเธออยู่ด้านบน ถึงแม้จริงๆ แล้ว
มันจะไม่ต่างกันในกรณีนี้ ผลก็คือ
สถานะ Phi plus ถูก
แมปไปเป็น Phi minus ซึ่งคุณสามารถดูจากสมการเหล่านี้ได้ถ้าจำวิธีทำงานของ Z-gate ได้
เราสามารถเพิ่มอันนี้ในตาราง ยังมีอีกสองกรณีที่ต้องดู ถ้า A เท่ากับหนึ่ง
และ B เท่ากับศูนย์
Alice จะทำ
X-gate ซึ่งเปลี่ยน Phi plus เป็น Chi plus และถ้า A เท่ากับหนึ่ง
และ B เท่ากับหนึ่ง
Alice จะทำ Z แล้ว
X แล้วเราจะได้ Chi minus
ตารางของเราบอกว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นในสี่กรณีที่เป็นไปได้ และนั่นก็คือ Alice เลือกได้ว่าจะใช้
Bell state ตัวไหนจากสี่ตัว
ที่เธอต้องการแชร์กับ Bob และเธอมีอิสระในการเลือกโดยกระทำกับ qubit ของเธอเพียงตัวเดียว
และนั่นเป็นแง่มุมที่น่าสนใจ
ของ entanglement
จากนั้น Alice ส่ง qubit ของเธอ
ให้ Bob ตอนนี้ Bob ถือ Bell state หนึ่งจากสี่ตัว และเขาแค่ต้อง
หาว่ามันเป็นตัวไหน
เพื่อกู้บิตคืนมา
และเราตรวจสอบได้ว่า
controlled NOT gate ตามด้วย Hadamard gate
อย่างที่เรามีในแผนภาพนั้นทำได้ถูกต้อง
ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียด แต่ถ้าคุณเลือกที่จะทำ คุณจะพบว่าผลลัพธ์เป็น
อย่างที่เห็นในตาราง
วิธีหนึ่งที่จะตรวจสอบ
คือแค่คำนวณ อีกทางหนึ่ง เราจำได้ว่าเราได้
ทำสิ่งนี้กลับด้านไปแล้ว
ในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า ในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า เรา
มี Hadamard gate ก่อน แล้ว controlled NOT gate ตามมา
แล้วเราเห็นว่า circuit นั้น
แมป standard basis state ไปเป็น Bell state โดยมี
เครื่องหมายลบน่ารำคาญในหนึ่งกรณี
เมื่อเราสลับลำดับของ gate และพิจารณาว่า
gate ทั้งสองตัวนี้เป็นอินเวิร์สของตัวเอง
สิ่งที่เราได้คืออินเวิร์ส
ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราได้ใน
กรณีนี้คือการกระทำไปในทิศทางตรงข้าม
และเครื่องหมายลบจะเลือกอยู่
ข้างไหนก็ได้
แต่นอกจากนั้น มันอยู่ที่ที่ควรอยู่ และตอนนี้
เห็นได้ทันทีว่าการวัดเผยค่าที่ถูกต้อง
เครื่องหมายลบตรงนี้ไม่ได้รบกวนเราเพราะหนึ่งปรากฏด้วย
ความน่าจะเป็นหนึ่งในกรณีนี้ และนั่นคือทั้งหมดของการวิเคราะห์
สรุปสั้นๆ Alice เลือก Bell state และ Bob หาว่ามันเป็นตัวไหน
พูดสั้นๆ สักเล็กน้อย
เกี่ยวกับ superdense coding ก่อนไปต่อ ประการแรก เราควรยอมรับ
ว่า superdense coding
อาจจะไม่น่าจะ
มีประโยชน์หรือเป็นจริงในทางปฏิบัติในแง่ของ
การส่งข้อมูลคลาสสิก
การสื่อสารคลาสสิก
ถูกมากและการส่ง qubit ทางกายภาพนั้นท้าทายอย่างน้อยที่สุด
และตราบใดที่เป็นเช่นนั้น เราจะไม่คาดหวัง
ข้อได้เปรียบในทางปฏิบัติเลยจาก superdense coding
แต่แค่เพราะมันไม่น่าจะ
เป็นจริงในทางปฏิบัติ ไม่ได้หมายความว่า superdense
coding ไม่น่าสนใจ
มันน่าสนใจมากจริงๆ อย่างหนึ่ง แนวคิดพื้นฐาน
ค่อนข้างเป็นรากฐานจริงๆ
และเมื่อผมพูดถึงแนวคิดพื้นฐาน ผมหมายถึงแนวคิดที่ว่าถ้า Alice
แชร์ Bell state กับ Bob
เธอสามารถเลือกที่จะเปลี่ยนสถานะนั้นเป็น Bell state อื่นใดก็ได้ที่
เธอเลือกด้วยตัวเอง เธอไม่ต้องการ
ความช่วยเหลือจาก Bob เลย
นี่เป็นตัวอย่างเฉพาะ
ที่เกี่ยวกับ Bell state แต่มีแนวคิดพื้นฐานที่กว้างกว่าเกี่ยวกับอิสระที่ผู้เล่นคนหนึ่ง
มีในการเปลี่ยนสถานะ entangled ที่แชร์กับผู้เล่นอีกคน และการเข้าใจอย่างแม่นยำ
ว่าอิสระนั้นคืออะไร
เป็นขั้นตอนสำคัญในการเข้าใจข้อมูลควอนตัม และเราจะเห็นวิธีอธิบายอิสระนั้นอย่างง่าย
และสง่างามในหน่วยที่สาม
ของซีรีส์
Superdense coding ยัง
เป็นตัวอย่างที่เป็นรูปธรรมของสิ่งที่คุณทำได้กับ entanglement ซึ่งก็คือช่วยให้ส่งบิตคลาสสิก
สองบิตได้
โดยส่ง qubit เดียว อย่างที่ผมพูดไปแล้ว
สิ่งนี้พิสูจน์ได้ว่าเป็นไปไม่ได้โดยทฤษฎีบท Holevo หากไม่มี entanglement
เรายังสามารถพิจารณา teleportation และ superdense coding ร่วมกัน และเราจะเห็นว่ามัน
สร้างความเท่าเทียม
ระหว่าง qubit หนึ่งตัวของการสื่อสารควอนตัม กับบิตคลาสสิกสองบิตของการสื่อสาร
ตราบใดที่คุณยอม
ใช้ e-bit หนึ่งตัว คุณสามารถ
แปลงอันหนึ่งเป็นอีกอันได้
Teleportation ช่วยให้
สื่อสาร qubit หนึ่งตัวโดยใช้บิตคลาสสิกสองบิต และ superdense coding ทำในทิศทางตรงข้าม
และช่วยให้ใช้บิตคลาสสิก
สองบิตโดยใช้ qubit หนึ่งตัวของการสื่อสารควอนตัม
แต่ถ้าไม่ใช้ e-bit คุณไม่สามารถแปลง
อันไหนเป็นอีกอันได้ entanglement ที่
ทำให้สิ่งนี้เป็นไปได้
ตัวอย่างที่สามและสุดท้าย
ที่เราจะพูดถึงในบทเรียนนี้ไม่ใช่โปรโตคอล แต่เป็น
เกมที่เรียกว่าเกม CHSH
เมื่อเราพูดถึงเกมในบริบทนี้ เราไม่ได้พูดถึงสิ่งที่เล่น
เพื่อความสนุกหรือกีฬา
แต่เป็นสิ่งที่เป็นนามธรรมทางคณิตศาสตร์ในแง่ของทฤษฎีเกม
สิ่งที่เป็นนามธรรมทางคณิตศาสตร์ของเกมถูกศึกษากันอย่างแพร่หลายใน
เศรษฐศาสตร์และวิทยาการคอมพิวเตอร์ และมี
คุณค่ามาก
ที่จะพบในความเป็นนามธรรม ดังนั้นเกมไม่ใช่เรื่องสนุกทั้งหมด
ในเกม ปรากฏว่า
ถึงแม้ว่ามันจะสนุกที่จะคิดเกี่ยวกับมัน
ในกรณีนี้ สิ่งที่เรามีคือ
การทดลองทางความคิดที่สามารถอธิบายได้อย่าง
เข้าใจง่ายเป็นเกม
ตัวอักษร CHSH อ้างถึงผู้เขียน John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony และ Richard Holt ของบทความปี 1969
ที่ตัวอย่างนี้
ถูกอธิบายครั้งแรก พวกเขาไม่ได้อธิบาย
มันเป็นเกมจริงๆ และเป็นเรื่องปกติ
ที่จะอ้างถึงตัวอย่างนี้
ไม่ใช่ว่าเกม CHSH แต่เป็น
CHSH inequality
แต่สำหรับนักวิทยาการคอมพิวเตอร์อย่างผม มันเป็นธรรมชาติมาก
ที่จะอธิบายมันเป็นเกม
ผมได้แนะนำไปแล้วว่า
สิ่งที่เป็นนามธรรมทางคณิตศาสตร์ของเกมทั้งสำคัญและมีประโยชน์ และมีหมวดหมู่
ของเกมที่แตกต่างกันมากมาย
ที่สามารถพิจารณาได้ เกม CHSH เป็น
ตัวอย่างของเกมประเภทที่เรียกว่า non-local game
นี่คือการตั้งค่าทั่วไป
สำหรับ non-local game
เรามีผู้เล่นสองคน Alice และ Bob ที่ร่วมมือกันเป็นทีม ดังนั้นพวกเขาชนะด้วยกัน
หรือแพ้ด้วยกัน
นี่หมายความว่าพวกเขาไม่มี
แรงจูงใจที่จะทำเพื่อตัวเอง ดังนั้นมันเป็นขั้วตรงข้าม
กับเกมผลรวมศูนย์
ซึ่งเป็นการแข่งขันล้วนๆ ตรงนี้เกมเป็นการร่วมมือล้วนๆ
มีบุคคลที่สามเรียกว่ากรรมการ
กรรมการไม่ใช่ผู้เล่นในเกม แต่กรรมการ
ดำเนินเกม และจริงๆ แล้ว คุณอาจมองว่าข้อกำหนด
ของ non-local game แต่ละอัน
และข้อกำหนดของ
กรรมการเป็นสิ่งที่เทียบเท่ากัน
มีข้อจำกัดที่สำคัญมากที่วางไว้สำหรับ Alice และ Bob คือเมื่อเกมเริ่ม พวกเขาถูกห้ามไม่ให้
สื่อสารกัน
พวกเขาสามารถตกลงกันล่วงหน้า
ว่าจะใช้กลยุทธ์อะไรก็ได้ แต่ไม่อนุญาต
ให้สื่อสารระหว่างเกม
ถ้าอยาก คุณสามารถ
จินตนาการว่าเกมเกิดขึ้นในสถานที่ปลอดภัยบางอย่าง ราวกับว่ากรรมการเล่น
บทบาทนักสืบ
และ Alice กับ Bob เป็นผู้ต้องสงสัยที่อยู่ใน
ห้องคนละห้องในสถานีตำรวจ แต่อีกวิธีคิด
เกี่ยวกับการตั้งค่า
คือ Alice และ Bob
ถูกแยกด้วยระยะทางไกลมาก และการสื่อสารถูกห้ามเพราะความเร็วแสง
ไม่อนุญาตให้สื่อสาร
ได้เร็วพอ ถ้า Alice พยายามส่ง
ข้อความถึง Bob เกมจะจบไป
ก่อนที่ Bob จะได้รับ
วิธีที่ non-local game
ทำงานคือ ก่อนอื่น กรรมการถาม
ทั้ง Alice และ Bob คำถาม
คำถามของ Alice ถูกเรียกว่า X และคำถามของ Bob ถูกเรียกว่า Y
โดยทั่วไป คุณสามารถมอง X และ Y เป็นสถานะคลาสสิก
จากสถานะคลาสสิกใดๆ ที่คุณต้องการ และใน
กรณีเฉพาะของเกม CHSH
X และ Y เป็นบิต
Alice และ Bob ต้องให้คำตอบ คำตอบของ Alice ถูกเรียกว่า A
และคำตอบของ Bob ถูกเรียกว่า B
และเช่นเดียวกัน คำตอบเหล่านี้สามารถมองเป็นสถานะคลาสสิกโดยทั่วไป และเหมือนคำถาม มันจะ
เป็นบิตในเกม CHSH
ณ จุดนี้
กรรมการตัดสินใจ Alice และ Bob ชนะหรือแพ้ขึ้นอยู่กับว่า
คู่คำตอบ A, B
ถูกตัดสินว่าถูกต้อง
สำหรับคู่คำถาม X, Y ที่กรรมการถาม และผมจะพูดเพิ่มเติม
เกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้อีกสักครู่
ก่อนอื่น มาดู
กรรมการให้ใกล้ชิดขึ้นเพื่อเข้าใจว่าอะไร
ที่อาจเป็นความท้าทายสำหรับ Alice และ Bob ใน non-local game
และสิ่งที่ทำให้ non-local
game อาจท้าทายคือกรรมการสามารถใช้ความสุ่มในการเลือกคำถาม X และ Y
นั่นหมายความว่า Alice
และ Bob มีความไม่แน่นอน พวกเขาไม่รู้ล่วงหน้าว่าจะถูกถามคำถามอะไร และที่อาจสำคัญกว่า
พวกเขาไม่รู้ว่าอีกคน
ได้รับคำถามอะไร และความไม่แน่นอนนั้น
ร่วมกับการที่พวกเขาสื่อสารกันไม่ได้
คือสิ่งที่สร้างความท้าทาย
ดังนั้น มันคล้ายกับสถานการณ์ที่นักสืบ
สอบปากคำผู้ต้องสงสัยสองคนในห้องคนละห้อง ถ้า
ผู้ต้องสงสัยไม่รู้
ว่าอีกคนถูกถามคำถามอะไร มันยากกว่ามากถ้าพวกเขาผิดจริงที่จะให้ปากคำตรงกัน
ตอนนี้ ผมพูดไปเมื่อ
สักครู่ว่ากรรมการตัดสิน
ว่า Alice และ Bob ตอบ
ถูกหรือผิด
ขึ้นอยู่กับคำถาม
ที่พวกเขาถูกถาม
สันนิษฐานว่าการตัดสิน
นี้ทำตามกฎที่แน่นอน
และคุณสามารถพิจารณากฎอะไรก็ได้ที่ต้องการ
แต่ไม่ว่ามันจะเป็นอะไร
สันนิษฐานว่า Alice
และ Bob รู้กฎ ดังนั้นอย่างน้อยพวกเขามี
โอกาสที่จะตอบถูก
เราจะดูกฎ
สำหรับเกม CHSH อีกสักครู่ แต่เรา
อาจพิจารณากฎอื่นแล้วเราจะได้
ตัวอย่างอื่นของ non-local game
non-local game บางอันน่าสนใจ และจริงๆ บางอันน่าหลงใหลมากลึกลับจนถึงทุกวันนี้ และ
บางอันก็ไม่น่าสนใจเท่าไหร่
นั่นเป็นแค่ธรรมชาติของ
โมเดล non-local game
อย่างไรก็ตาม นี่คือสองสิ่งที่จำเป็นในการอธิบายกรรมการ คำถามถูกเลือกอย่างไร
และคู่คำตอบไหนถูกต้องสำหรับแต่ละคู่คำถามที่เป็นไปได้
ถ้าเรามีคำอธิบาย
ของสองสิ่งนั้น เราก็มีคำอธิบายสำหรับกรรมการ และนั่นก็อธิบาย
non-local game ตัวหนึ่งได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
ทีนี้มาดูเกม CHSH
โดยเฉพาะ
วิธีที่เกมถูกกำหนด
หรือเทียบเท่ากัน วิธีที่กรรมการถูกกำหนดเป็นดังนี้
ประการแรก อย่างที่ผมพูดไปแล้ว คำถามและคำตอบเป็นบิตทั้งหมด ดังนั้นกรรมการส่งบิต X
ให้ Alice และบิต Y ให้ Bob
และแต่ละคนตอบด้วยบิต Alice ตอบด้วย A
และ Bob ตอบด้วย B
วิธีที่กรรมการเลือก
ว่าจะถามคำถามอะไรนั้นง่าย เขาเลือก
แบบสุ่มเท่าๆ กัน
ดังนั้น คู่คำถาม X, Y มีโอกาสเท่ากันที่จะเป็นหนึ่ง
ในสี่ความเป็นไปได้ คือศูนย์ศูนย์ ศูนย์หนึ่ง
หนึ่งศูนย์ และหนึ่งหนึ่ง
สุดท้าย กฎที่
กำหนดว่าคำตอบไหนชนะและคำตอบไหนแพ้คือ
คู่คำตอบ A, B ถูกต้องสำหรับคู่คำถาม X, Y
ก็ต่อเมื่อ exclusive or ของ A และ B เท่ากับ logical and ของ X และ Y
นั่นอาจจะย่อยง่ายกว่าถ้าเราแสดงเงื่อนไขเหล่านั้น
ในรูปแบบตารางอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
ในคอลัมน์แรก เรามีคู่คำถามสี่คู่ที่เป็นไปได้ และในคอลัมน์ที่สอง เรา
มีเงื่อนไขของ A และ B
ที่จำเป็นเพื่อให้
Alice และ Bob ชนะ
ในสามกรณีแรก
and ของ A และ Y เป็นศูนย์ ดังนั้น exclusive or ต้องเท่ากับศูนย์
เพื่อที่จะชนะ
และนั่นก็เหมือนกับบอกว่า A และ B ต้องเท่ากัน เพราะ A และ B เป็นบิต
และในกรณีที่สี่
and ของ X และ Y เท่ากับ
หนึ่ง ดังนั้น exclusive or ของ A และ B ต้องเท่ากับหนึ่งเพื่อให้ Alice และ Bob ชนะ
และนั่นก็เหมือนกับ
บอกว่า A และ B ต้องต่างกัน
นั่นคือเกม CHSH และตอนนี้เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
กลยุทธ์ต่างๆ สำหรับ Alice และ Bob และพวกเขา
ทำได้ดีแค่ไหนในเกมนี้
มาเริ่มด้วยการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
กลยุทธ์แบบกำหนดแน่นอน ที่คำตอบ A ของ Alice เป็น
ฟังก์ชันของคำถาม X ที่เธอได้รับ และ
เช่นเดียวกัน คำตอบ B ของ Bob
เป็นฟังก์ชันของ
คำถาม Y ที่เขาได้รับ
และปรากฏว่า ไม่มี
กลยุทธ์แบบกำหนดแน่นอนที่จะชนะได้ทุกครั้ง
วิธีหนึ่งที่จะให้เหตุผลคือ
แค่ไล่ดูกลยุทธ์แบบกำหนดแน่นอน
ที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งหมดทีละตัว แล้วตรวจสอบว่าทุกตัวแพ้
สำหรับอย่างน้อยหนึ่งใน
สี่คู่คำถามที่เป็นไปได้
Alice และ Bob แต่ละคน
มีฟังก์ชันให้เลือกสี่ตัว เราเห็นฟังก์ชัน
สี่ตัวนั้นในบทเรียนที่หนึ่ง ดังนั้นมี 16 ความเป็นไปได้
ที่ต้องตรวจสอบ
อีกวิธีที่จะเห็นคือ
คิดเกี่ยวกับสมการตรงหน้าจอ เรากำลังคิด
เกี่ยวกับกลยุทธ์แบบกำหนดแน่นอน
ที่ A และ B เป็นฟังก์ชัน
ของ X และ Y ตามลำดับ
ตัวอย่างเช่น A ของศูนย์
แทนคำตอบของ Alice เมื่อคำถาม X เท่ากับศูนย์ และ a ของหนึ่ง แทนคำตอบของ Alice
เมื่อคำถาม X เท่ากับหนึ่ง
นี่คือสี่สมการ
ที่ต้องเป็นจริงเพื่อให้เงื่อนไข
การชนะถูกต้องในทั้งสี่กรณี
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า X เท่ากับ
ศูนย์ และ Y เท่ากับศูนย์ exclusive or ของ A
และ B ต้องเท่ากับศูนย์
ในขณะที่กรณี X เท่ากับหนึ่ง และ Y เท่ากับหนึ่ง
exclusive or ของ A และ B ต้องเท่ากับหนึ่ง
วิธีหนึ่งที่เราเห็นว่า
ไม่มีทางเลือกฟังก์ชัน A และ B ให้
สมการเหล่านี้เป็นจริงทั้งหมดได้ คือแค่หา exclusive
or ของสมการทั้งหมด
exclusive or ของค่า
ไบนารีใดๆ กับตัวเองเท่ากับศูนย์ และดังนั้นจึงตามมาว่า exclusive or
ของด้านซ้ายทั้งหมด
เท่ากับศูนย์ นั่นเพราะ
เรามีสองตัวของ a ศูนย์ สองตัวของ a หนึ่ง
สองตัวของ B ศูนย์
และสองตัวของ B หนึ่ง
ดังนั้น xor ทั้งหมดเข้าด้วยกัน
ให้คำตอบสุดท้ายเป็นศูนย์ แต่ถ้าเราหา exclusive or ของด้านขวาของสมการ
เราจะได้หนึ่ง ไม่ใช่ศูนย์ ดังนั้นสี่สมการ
เป็นจริงพร้อมกันทั้งหมดไม่ได้ อย่างน้อยหนึ่งสมการต้องผิด
และนั่นจะนำไปสู่
การแพ้ของ Alice และ Bob ในอย่างน้อยหนึ่งจากสี่กรณี
และดังนั้นจึงตามมาเพราะกรรมการเลือกคำถาม
อย่างสม่ำเสมอว่าความน่าจะเป็นที่ Alice และ Bob จะชนะ
ด้วยกลยุทธ์แบบกำหนดแน่นอน
มากที่สุดคือสามในสี่ หรือ 75%
ความจริงที่ว่า Alice และ Bob สามารถชนะได้ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสามในสี่นั้นเห็นได้ง่าย
จริงๆ ถ้า Alice และ Bob ตอบศูนย์
ตลอดเวลา
พวกเขาจะถูกสาม
จากสี่ครั้ง
ดังนั้น Alice และ Bob ทำได้ดี
กว่าการชนะ 75% ของเวลาด้วยกลยุทธ์
แบบกำหนดแน่นอนไม่ได้
แล้วกลยุทธ์แบบความน่าจะเป็นล่ะ?
ปรากฏว่าการใช้
กลยุทธ์แบบความน่าจะเป็นช่วยพวกเขาไม่ได้เลย นั่นเพราะทุกกลยุทธ์
แบบความน่าจะเป็น
สามารถมองอีกแบบว่า
เป็นการเลือกสุ่มของกลยุทธ์แบบกำหนดแน่นอน เหมือนที่การดำเนินการ
แบบความน่าจะเป็นสามารถมองว่า
เป็นการเลือกสุ่มของ
การดำเนินการแบบกำหนดแน่นอน อย่างที่เราเห็นในบทเรียนแรก
ค่าเฉลี่ยไม่เคย
มากกว่าค่าสูงสุด ดังนั้นจึงตามมาว่า
กลยุทธ์แบบความน่าจะเป็นไม่ให้
ข้อได้เปรียบใดๆ ในแง่ของการชนะ
เหนือกลยุทธ์แบบกำหนดแน่นอน นี่รวมถึงความเป็นไปได้ที่การเลือกสุ่มของ Alice และ Bob
มีความสัมพันธ์กัน
ดังนั้น สรุปคือชนะด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสามในสี่คือดีที่สุดที่ Alice
และ Bob ทำได้ด้วยกลยุทธ์คลาสสิกใดๆ
ไม่ว่าจะเป็นแบบกำหนดแน่นอน
หรือแบบความน่าจะเป็น
คำถามตามธรรมชาติที่จะถาม ณ จุดนี้คือ Alice และ Bob สามารถทำได้ดีกว่าด้วยกลยุทธ์ควอนตัมหรือเปล่า
และโดยเฉพาะ
ถ้าพวกเขาแชร์สถานะควอนตัม entangled ซึ่งพวกเขาอาจเตรียมไว้
ก่อนเล่นเกม มันช่วยได้หรือเปล่า?
คำตอบคือได้ มันช่วยได้ และนั่นคือประเด็นของตัวอย่างนี้ และนั่นคือเหตุผลที่มันน่าสนใจมาก
มาดูกันว่า Alice
และ Bob ทำได้ดีกว่าในเกมนี้โดยใช้ entanglement อย่างไร
สิ่งแรกที่เราต้องทำคือกำหนดเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม Chi
theta สำหรับแต่ละมุม theta อย่างที่เห็นตรงหน้าจอ
Chi theta เท่ากับ
cosine theta คูณ ket ศูนย์ บวก sine theta คูณ ket
หนึ่ง และตรงนี้
เรากำลังคิดเกี่ยวกับ
มุมในหน่วยเรเดียน
ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือเวกเตอร์ที่ได้เมื่อ theta เท่ากับ pi หารสี่
ซึ่งคือ 45 องศา
cosine ของ pi หารสี่
และ sine ของ pi หารสี่ เท่ากับหนึ่งหาร
รากที่สองของสอง ทั้งคู่ ดังนั้นนี่เป็นแค่
ชื่ออื่นของสถานะบวก
นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างเมื่อ theta เท่ากับสามคูณ pi หารแปด และในกรณีที่คุณไม่
ทราบค่า sine
และ cosine ของสามคูณ pi หารแปดจากหัว
นี่คือตารางของค่า sine และ cosine ที่เราจะ
ต้องใช้จริงๆ
ตลอดตัวอย่างนี้
และรวมถึงค่าที่เราต้องการสำหรับเวกเตอร์นี้ด้วย
ทีนี้ ถ้าเราต้องการหา inner product ระหว่างเวกเตอร์สองตัวใดๆ เหล่านี้
สำหรับมุม alpha และ beta สมมติ มัน
ทำได้ตรงไปตรงมา
เรามีเฉพาะจำนวนจริง
ในเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ ดังนั้นไม่ต้องห่วงเรื่อง
สังยุคเชิงซ้อน และเราได้ผลคูณของ cosine
บวกผลคูณของ sine และเราสามารถใช้สูตร
การบวกมุม
เพื่อทำให้ง่ายขึ้น มันคือ
cosine ของผลต่างระหว่างมุม และ
เพราะฟังก์ชัน cosine
สมมาตรรอบศูนย์
จริงๆ แล้วไม่สำคัญว่าจะลำดับไหน
ถ้าคุณจำเอกลักษณ์
ตรีโกณมิติพวกนี้ไม่ได้ คุณ
ไม่ได้อยู่คนเดียว แต่คุณไม่ต้องจำมัน
แค่ค้นหาก็ได้ อันนี้ก็สมเหตุสมผล
ถ้าคิดเกี่ยวกับการตีความทางเรขาคณิต
ของ inner product
ระหว่างเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยจริงเป็น cosine ของมุมระหว่างมัน
ถ้าเราคำนวณ inner
product ของ tensor product ของเวกเตอร์สองตัวเหล่านี้
กับสถานะ Phi plus เราจะได้นิพจน์ที่คล้ายกัน
ยกเว้นว่ามีรากที่สอง
ของสองในตัวหาร
นี่เป็นครั้งแรก
ที่สถานะ Phi plus ปรากฏในบริบท
ของตัวอย่างนี้ และเราจะเห็นว่าทำไมเราสนใจ
inner product นี้ในอีกสักครู่ แต่ตอนนี้
แค่สังเกตว่าเราได้นิพจน์เดียวกันกับที่มี
สำหรับ inner product หาร
ด้วยรากที่สองของสอง ดังนั้นเราทำให้ง่ายขึ้นได้เหมือนเดิม
ต่อไป เราจะกำหนด
เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี U theta สำหรับแต่ละมุม theta
อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
ไม่ยากที่จะ
ตรวจสอบว่านี่เป็นเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีจริง
สิ่งสำคัญที่เราต้อง
ตระหนักคือเวกเตอร์ si theta ตั้งฉากกับ
เวกเตอร์ si theta บวก pi หารสอง และนั่นสมเหตุสมผล
เพราะถ้าเราหมุน pi หารสอง ซึ่งคือ 90 องศา เรา
จะได้เวกเตอร์ตั้งฉาก
ถ้าเราคูณ U
theta กับ U theta dagger เราจะได้เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์
พูดโดยสัญชาตญาณ
สิ่งที่เมทริกซ์นี้ทำในฐานะการดำเนินการคือ
แมป si theta ไป ket ศูนย์ และ si theta บวก pi หารสอง ไป ket หนึ่ง
ณ จุดนี้ เรามี
ทุกอย่างที่ต้องการเพื่ออธิบายกลยุทธ์ของ Alice และ Bob
ประการแรก เหมือนกับที่เรามีสำหรับ teleportation และ superdense coding Alice และ Bob จะเริ่มด้วยการแชร์ e-bit
Alice ถือ qubit A
Bob ถือ qubit B และ qubit สองตัวรวมกัน
อยู่ในสถานะ Phi plus
การกระทำของ Alice เป็นดังนี้ เธอดูบิต X ที่
เธอได้รับจากกรรมการ
และถ้า X เท่ากับศูนย์
เธอทำ U ศูนย์ บน A ซึ่งบังเอิญ
เหมือนกับไม่ทำอะไร เพราะ U ศูนย์ คือเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์
ถ้า X เท่ากับหนึ่ง เธอจะใช้ U pi หารสี่ กับ A
หลังจากเธอใช้การดำเนินการ
อย่างใดอย่างหนึ่ง เธอวัด A ด้วย
standard basis measurement แล้วส่งผลลัพธ์ที่ได้
ให้กรรมการ
Bob ทำคล้ายกันมาก qubit ของเขาเรียก B แน่นอน และเขาได้รับ Y จาก
กรรมการแทน X
แต่ความแตกต่างสำคัญคือ
เขาใช้มุมต่างกันสำหรับการดำเนินการยูนิทารี
ถ้า Y เท่ากับศูนย์ เขา
ใช้ U pi หารแปด และถ้า Y เท่ากับหนึ่ง เขาใช้ U ลบ pi หารแปด
และเราจะเห็นว่าทำไมการเลือกมุมเหล่านี้เป็นตัวเลือกที่ดีในอีกสักครู่
มันไม่ชัดเจนเลย
และนี่คือแผนภาพ circuit
ที่แสดงกลยุทธ์นี้
Bob อยู่ด้านบน และ Alice
อยู่ด้านล่างคราวนี้ นี่คือ e-bit ที่เข้ามา
และนี่คือ gate ยูนิทารี
ที่ Alice และ Bob อาจใช้หรือไม่ใช้
ขึ้นอยู่กับว่า X และ Y เป็นอะไร
สำหรับอันนี้และอันนี้ เรามี gate ที่ถูกควบคุมด้วยบิต X หรือบิต Y
และสำหรับสองตัวตรงนี้ เรามีสิ่งที่ดู
เหมือน control gate ยกเว้นว่าวงกลมไม่ได้ถูกเติม
และความหมายคือ
ถ้าบิตควบคุมเป็นศูนย์ gate จะทำงาน และถ้าบิตควบคุมเป็น
หนึ่ง ไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้น
มันเหมือน
control gate ธรรมดา ยกเว้นว่าบทบาทของศูนย์และหนึ่งสำหรับตัวควบคุมถูกสลับกัน
ดังนั้น Bob
ทำ gate ตรงนี้ถ้า Y เท่ากับศูนย์ เขา
ทำ gate ตรงนี้
ถ้า Y เท่ากับหนึ่ง และเช่นเดียวกัน Alice ทำ gate ตรง
นี้ถ้า X เท่ากับศูนย์ และ gate ตรงนี้
ถ้า X เท่ากับหนึ่ง
นั่นคือกลยุทธ์ของ Alice และ Bob และตอนนี้เราแค่ต้อง
หาว่ามันทำงานได้ดีแค่ไหน
สำหรับการวิเคราะห์กลยุทธ์ควอนตัมที่ผมเพิ่งอธิบาย เรา
จริงๆ ต้องการแค่สองสิ่ง ณ จุดนี้ ประการแรก
เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี U Theta
เป็นอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ และ
ประการที่สอง เรามีสูตรนี้
เราไม่จำเป็นต้องใช้นิยามของเวกเตอร์ si theta อีกต่อไปแล้ว สมการสองตัวนี้คือทั้งหมดที่เราต้องการ
มีสี่กรณีที่ต้อง
พิจารณา เริ่มจากกรณีที่หนึ่ง คือ X เท่ากับ
ศูนย์ และ Y เท่ากับศูนย์
และถ้าเราดูกลับไปที่กลยุทธ์ เราจะพบว่าใน
กรณีนี้ Alice ทำ U ศูนย์ บน qubit ของเธอ และ Bob ทำ
U pi หารแปด บน qubit ของเขา
จำไว้ว่า Alice อยู่
ด้านล่าง และ Bob อยู่ด้านบน ดังนั้นสถานะที่พวกเขา
ได้จะเป็นแบบนี้
และเมื่อขยายมันออก
ตามนิยามของ U theta เราจะได้
นิพจน์ที่เห็นตรงนี้
เราไม่ต้องขยาย
มันออกอีกเพราะเรามี
สูตรอีกตัวช่วย
และถ้าเราใช้สูตรนั้น
สำหรับแต่ละพจน์จากสี่พจน์ สิ่งที่เราได้คือนี่
ณ จุดนี้ Alice และ Bob ทั้งคู่วัด และนี่คือตารางที่
อธิบายการกระจายของผลลัพธ์
เราหาค่าสัมบูรณ์
ยกกำลังสองของสัมประสิทธิ์เพื่อให้ได้ความน่าจะเป็น ซึ่งบังเอิญเป็นค่า
ยกกำลังสองของสัมประสิทธิ์
เพราะสัมประสิทธิ์เป็น
จำนวนจริงทั้งหมดในกรณีนี้
ถ้าเราใช้ค่า
sine และ cosine จากก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน
ร่วมกับสมมาตรบางอย่าง เราสามารถแสดงความน่าจะเป็น
อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
ในคอลัมน์สุดท้าย
ทีนี้ สิ่งที่เราสนใจจริงๆ
คือความน่าจะเป็นที่พวกเขาชนะ และจำไว้ว่า ในกรณีที่ X และ Y เป็นศูนย์ทั้งคู่
พวกเขาชนะถ้า A และ B เท่ากัน และแพ้ถ้า A และ B ไม่เท่ากัน
ถ้าเราคำนวณความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านั้น เราจะพบว่าความน่าจะเป็น
ที่ A และ B เท่ากันคือผลรวมของจำนวนนี้และจำนวนนี้
ซึ่งเท่ากับสองบวก
รากที่สองของสอง ทั้งหมดหารสี่ ซึ่งประมาณ 85%
ความน่าจะเป็นที่ A และ B ไม่เท่ากันคือสองลบรากที่สองของสอง ทั้งหมดหารสี่ ซึ่งเป็นธรรมชาติว่าเท่ากับหนึ่งลบปริมาณ
ที่เราเพิ่งคำนวณไป ดังนั้น
พวกเขาชนะด้วยความน่าจะเป็นประมาณ 85% ในกรณีนี้
ยังมีอีกสามกรณีที่ต้องพิจารณา แต่มันคล้ายกับกรณีนี้มาก
ในกรณีที่ X เท่ากับ
ศูนย์ และ Y เท่ากับหนึ่ง Bob ใช้ U ลบ pi หารแปด แทน U pi หารแปด
ค่าในสูตร
เปลี่ยนไปบ้าง แต่เราได้ความน่าจะเป็น
เดียวกันกับกรณีก่อนหน้า
เมื่อ X เท่ากับศูนย์ และ Y เท่ากับหนึ่ง Alice และ Bob ยังคงชนะ
เมื่อ A และ B เท่ากัน ดังนั้นเราได้ความน่าจะเป็น
ชนะเท่าเดิม
เหมือนเดิม
ในกรณีที่สาม เมื่อ X เท่ากับหนึ่ง และ Y เท่ากับศูนย์ เรา
มีสถานการณ์คล้ายกัน มุมต่างกัน
แต่มีความสัมพันธ์กัน
เหมือนกันเป๊ะ
และจริงๆ แล้ว เราได้เวกเตอร์
เดียวกันกับกรณีก่อนหน้า
ดังนั้นความน่าจะเป็นเหมือนกัน และความน่าจะเป็นชนะก็เหมือนกัน
กรณีสุดท้ายแตกต่าง
อยู่บ้างอย่างที่เราอาจคาดเพราะเงื่อนไข
การชนะต่างกันในกรณีนี้
เมื่อ X และ Y เท่ากับหนึ่งทั้งคู่ Alice และ Bob ชนะเมื่อ
A และ B ต่างกัน
วิธีการพื้นฐานเหมือนกัน ถึงแม้มุมจะต่างกัน คราวนี้ เราได้เวกเตอร์ตรงนี้
และคุณตรวจสอบได้โดยทำการลบที่จำเป็น
ความน่าจะเป็นเปลี่ยนในที่สุด และถ้าเราดูค่าที่ต้องการ เราจะเห็นว่าความน่าจะเป็น
สลับตำแหน่ง
จากเดิม ดังนั้นคราวนี้ความน่าจะเป็น
ที่ A ไม่เท่ากับ B คือค่าที่มากกว่าจากสองค่า
แต่นั่นดีเพราะในกรณีนี้ Alice และ Bob ชนะเมื่อ
A และ B ไม่เท่ากัน
ดังนั้นอีกครั้ง พวกเขาชนะด้วย
ความน่าจะเป็นประมาณ 85%
เมื่อพวกเขาชนะทุก
กรณีด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเดียวกัน ซึ่งก็คือสองบวกรากที่สองของสอง
ทั้งหมดหารสี่ หรือประมาณ 85%
นั่นคือความน่าจะเป็น
ที่พวกเขาชนะโดยรวม
ดีกว่ากลยุทธ์คลาสสิกใดๆ ในเกมนี้ และนั่นคือ
สิ่งที่ทำให้มันน่าสนใจ
นี่เป็นความน่าจะเป็น
ชนะที่เหมาะสมที่สุดสำหรับกลยุทธ์ควอนตัมใดๆ คุณ
ทำดีกว่านี้ด้วยสถานะ entangled ใดๆ ไม่ได้
ข้อเท็จจริงนี้เรียกว่า Tsirelson inequality ตั้งชื่อตาม Boris
Tsirelson ผู้พิสูจน์มันเป็นคนแรก และเท่าที่ผมทราบ เป็น
หนึ่งในคนแรกๆ
ที่อธิบายตัวอย่างนี้เป็นเกม ในกรณีที่การวิเคราะห์
ที่เราเพิ่งผ่านมาดูลึกลับนิดหน่อย
เป็นไปได้ที่จะคิด
เกี่ยวกับมันในเชิงเรขาคณิต ซึ่งอาจช่วย
ให้คุณเข้าใจการเลือกมุมได้ดีขึ้น
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเราใช้
สูตรที่เห็นตรงนี้ ซึ่งเราสรุปได้ง่าย
จากนิพจน์
ที่เราหามาแล้ว
สำหรับ inner product ที่เกี่ยวข้อง เราก็สามารถ
แสดงความน่าจะเป็นของผลลัพธ์
การวัดต่างๆ
ในสี่กรณีดังนี้ ก่อน ถ้า X, Y เท่ากับศูนย์ ศูนย์ นี่คือความน่าจะเป็น
ของผลลัพธ์การวัดต่างๆ และคุณต้องย้อนคิดหรือย้อนดูการวิเคราะห์
ที่เราเพิ่งผ่านมาเพื่อสรุปได้โดยใช้สูตรของเรา
ตรงนี้ เราเห็นเวกเตอร์
สถานะต่างๆ วาดอย่างที่เคย และการใช้สีตรงนี้
คือน้ำเงินแทน
ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์ และแดง
แทนผลลัพธ์หนึ่ง
คุณจะเห็นว่ามุม
ระหว่างเวกเตอร์น้ำเงินและมุมระหว่าง
เวกเตอร์แดงค่อนข้างเล็ก
เป็น pi หารแปด ทั้งสองกรณี ดังนั้น cosine ค่อนข้างมาก และนั่นหมายความว่า
ความน่าจะเป็นที่ผลลัพธ์สองตัว
เท่ากันนั้นค่อนข้างมาก
ในกรณีที่ X, Y เท่ากับศูนย์ หนึ่ง เป็นสถานการณ์คล้ายกัน
มุมระหว่างเวกเตอร์ที่มีสีเดียวกันเล็ก
ดังนั้นความน่าจะเป็นของ
ผลลัพธ์ที่เท่ากันจึงค่อนข้างมากอีกครั้ง
กรณีที่สามก็คล้ายกัน และในกรณีที่สี่
เมื่อ X, Y เท่ากับหนึ่ง หนึ่ง มีสิ่งที่น่าสนใจเกิดขึ้น คราวนี้ จากวิธี
ที่เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ถูกเลือก เราเห็นว่ามุมระหว่าง
เวกเตอร์ที่มีสีเดียวกัน
ค่อนข้างมาก และโดยเฉพาะมุมคือสามคูณ
pi หารแปด ทั้งสองกรณี
นี่หมายความว่าความน่าจะเป็น
ที่ผลลัพธ์การวัดเท่ากันค่อนข้างน้อย แต่นี่เป็นกรณีเดียว
ที่ Alice และ Bob ชนะ
เมื่อคำตอบของพวกเขาไม่ตรงกัน
ดังนั้นเป็นสิ่งที่เราต้องการ
อีกครั้ง นี่คือเวกเตอร์ เมื่อ X, Y เท่ากับศูนย์ ศูนย์
เมื่อ X, Y เท่ากับศูนย์ หนึ่ง
เมื่อ X, Y เท่ากับหนึ่ง ศูนย์
และเมื่อ X, Y เท่ากับหนึ่ง หนึ่ง
และบางทีภาพทาง
เรขาคณิตนี้อาจช่วยสร้าง
สัญชาตญาณว่ากลยุทธ์นี้ทำงานอย่างไร
และทำไมมุมต่างๆ ถึงถูกเลือกในแบบที่มันเป็น
เพื่อจบบทเรียน ผมจะพูดสั้นๆ สักนิด
เกี่ยวกับเกม CHSH
ประการแรก อย่างที่ผมพูดไปแล้ว ตัวอย่างนี้ไม่ได้ถูก
อธิบายเป็นเกมเสมอไป
ในชุมชนฟิสิกส์ เป็นเรื่องปกติกว่าที่
ตัวอย่างจะถูกอธิบายเป็นการทดลองมากกว่าเกม
และ Alice กับ Bob ถูก
มองว่าเป็นเครื่องตรวจจับมากกว่าผู้เล่น
แนวคิดพื้นฐานของการทดลองแบบนี้ที่ entanglement นำไปสู่
ผลลัพธ์ทางสถิติที่ไม่สอดคล้องกับ
คำอธิบายคลาสสิกใดๆ
หรือโดยทั่วไปกว่า
ทฤษฎีที่อิงบน local hidden variable
เป็นผลงานของ John Bell ผู้ที่ Bell state ตั้งชื่อตาม
ดังนั้นคนมักจะเรียก
การทดลองแบบนี้ว่า Bell test
บางครั้งคนยัง
อ้างถึงทฤษฎีบท Bell ซึ่งสามารถกำหนดได้หลายรูปแบบ แต่โดยพื้นฐานแล้วบอกว่า
กลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
ไม่สอดคล้องกับทฤษฎี local hidden variable
เกม CHSH หรืออสมการเป็นตัวอย่างที่สวยงามและชัดเจน
ของ Bell test
และคุณสามารถมอง
ตัวอย่างนี้เป็นการพิสูจน์หรือการสาธิตทฤษฎีบท Bell
ข้อสังเกตที่สองคือเกม CHSH ให้วิธีหนึ่งแก่เราในการทดสอบเชิงทดลองว่าทฤษฎีข้อมูลควอนตัม
เป็นทฤษฎีที่ถูกต้อง เราสามารถตั้งการทดลองที่ดำเนินเกม CHSH จริงๆ
รวมถึงกลยุทธ์แบบ
ที่อิงบน entanglement ที่ผมเพิ่งอธิบาย และ
ดูว่ามันทำงานหรือเปล่า และมันทำงาน
สิ่งนี้ให้ความมั่นใจ
สูงแก่เราว่า entanglement เป็นจริง และไม่เหมือนวิธีที่
คลุมเครือหรือบทกวี
ที่เราพยายามคิดขึ้นมา
เพื่ออธิบาย entanglement เกม CHSH หรือการทดลอง
ให้วิธีที่เป็นรูปธรรม
และทดสอบได้ในการสังเกต entanglement
ถ้านั่นฟังดูสำคัญ
ก็เพราะมันสำคัญจริง และรางวัลโนเบลสาขาฟิสิกส์
ปี 2022 ยอมรับสิ่งนี้พอดี
รางวัลถูกมอบให้
Alain Aspect, John Clauser ซึ่งเป็น C ใน CHSH และ Anton Zeilinger
สำหรับการทดลองกับโฟตอน entangled ที่พิสูจน์การละเมิด
Bell inequality หรือพูดอีกอย่าง
แสดงว่ากลยุทธ์ควอนตัม
แบบที่ผมอธิบายทำงานจริงและทำได้ดีกว่ากลยุทธ์คลาสสิก
และถ้าคุณสนใจ
เรียนรู้เพิ่มเติม ผมแนะนำให้ดู
วิดีโอเกี่ยวกับทฤษฎีบท Bell โดยเพื่อนร่วมงานของผม Olivia Lanes
ตรงนี้บนช่อง YouTube ของ Qiskit
และสุดท้าย หัวข้อของ
non-local game โดยทั่วไปนั้นน่าหลงใหลจริงๆ และเป็น
พื้นที่วิจัยที่ยังดำเนินอยู่
ที่นำฟิสิกส์
วิทยาการคอมพิวเตอร์ และคณิตศาสตร์บริสุทธิ์มารวมกัน และยังมีคำถาม
ที่น่าสนใจมากมาย
เกี่ยวกับ non-local game ที่
ยังไม่มีคำตอบจนถึงทุกวันนี้
และนั่นคือจบบทเรียนที่สี่ รวมถึงจบ
หน่วยที่หนึ่งของซีรีส์เกี่ยวกับพื้นฐานของข้อมูลควอนตัม
บทเรียนแรกอธิบาย
วิธีที่ข้อมูลควอนตัมทำงานสำหรับระบบเดี่ยวแบบแยกเดี่ยว และบทเรียนที่สองอธิบาย
วิธีที่ข้อมูลควอนตัม
ทำงานสำหรับหลายระบบ
ซึ่งเกิดขึ้นอย่างเป็นธรรมชาติจากวิธีที่มันทำงานสำหรับระบบเดี่ยว
บทเรียนที่สามแนะนำ
โมเดลการคำนวณแบบ quantum circuit และในบทเรียนที่สี่ เราได้ดูตัวอย่างสำคัญสามตัวอย่าง
ที่แสดงให้เห็นสิ่งที่เรา
ทำได้ด้วย entanglement
ระหว่างทาง เราได้เห็นแนวคิดทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่สำคัญมาก
รวมถึง tensor product และ inner product และเราได้สังเกต
ข้อจำกัดพื้นฐาน
ของข้อมูลควอนตัม
หวังว่าจะได้เจอกันอีกใน
หน่วยถัดไปของซีรีส์นี้ ซึ่งจะเกี่ยวกับ quantum algorithm โดยเราจะโฟกัสที่คำถาม
ว่าข้อมูลควอนตัมให้ข้อได้เปรียบ
ทางการคำนวณอะไรบ้าง
ลาก่อน แล้วเจอกันนะ